if you're here tonight thank you for
coming if you are not here tonight
welcome it is of course okay that you
couldn't make it and we've been thinking
about you
between the time this was recorded and
now several times and then exponentially
more after the recording wherever you
are starting now here but well before
now there know that you have been in our
thoughts often this is something we only
expect from those close family members
and long-lost friends but here we are a
room full of strangers thinking about
you on your train to work in New York
your coat matches your shoes nice in
Sweden riding your bicycle to the fish
market your cheeks flush with color it's
cold out there
I wish I spoke Swedish so I could tell
you something nice in Texas on your way
to the barbecue restaurant the one that
sells cigarettes and makes fresh
lemonade we love that noise I wish I
spoke Texas so I could tell you
something racist
you may have found us by chance or may
have been looking for us in either case
we have thought about you specifically
you once says stand up is for crippled
narcissists fine you once said stand up
is the only true art correct
maybe not the only true art some say
it's vegan pastries some say it's the
apology email some say it's the rolling
stop some say that the only true art is
forcing the one thing that you know
about a topic into a conversation about
that topic regardless of whether or not
it is constructive but all of you are
correct and no sign language is not
universal that couldn't be further from
the truth
not only are they all different
oftentimes countries have different sign
languages you would have been closer to
the truth if you had said all verbal
languages are the same why would you say
that it was very wrong and you said it
way too quickly thank you for making me
look that up
you're the crippled narcissist some of
you are the same person from before it's
understood that you have only now began
to think of us we're not worried about
any inequity in this relationship or
happy to be thinking about you and how
you're here thinking about us it was the
earliest you could have reasonably been
expected to do so all is forgiven and
thank you for thinking of us several
times and then exponentially more after
this recording all right guys let's do
this
[Music]
thank you guys man happier what an honor
thank you for being here
I couldn't I couldn't imagine a better
night I'm just glad there wasn't a mass
shooting today that's all I really care
about
guys my name is nate I'm a good person I
just want to start off by saying that
you can't tell these days
ladies I mean it's your world okay I'm
on board I'm all caught up on Handmaid's
Tale I sit down to pee now
no I've sat down to pee for a while
smartphones ever since I've pretty much
been a hard feminist ever since I got my
Galaxy s8 you got to be productive
fellas be productive if you're not
sitting down to pee I don't know what
the hell you're doing with your time
it's a woman's economy stay competitive
what are you doing up there you're
pissing on your shoes that's what you're
doing you're up here pissing on your
shoes the rest of us are down here
running several small businesses for one
fortune 500 company
I'm doing most of my work on the toilet
at this point no ladies hopefully men
are taking this opportunity to correct
their behavior I you know I I hated Pepe
LePew I always hated Pepe LePew
I I didn't understand it it caused me
anxiety as a young boy I was confused I
didn't know why this rape squirrel was
what is this who is this squirrel who
rapes and why is that what we have to do
to enjoy our favorite time of the week
the squirrel who rapes I know I know it
was a skunk but I was focused on the
rape really I was I didn't have time to
parse the small mammals there was a
full-on rape going on that's just as
strange it was strange
it taught me that you know men could be
animals because somebody had to
somebody did Pepe LePew somebody made
that that's an odd legacy for an artist
it's a very strange way to handle your
sexual deviance ease you know illustrate
them and show them to children no I mean
I'm a good I'm a good person I've always
been a good person I don't identify with
jerking off in front of someone I didn't
know that was a thing I've never tried
it if I had I'd still be doing it I
wouldn't have been able to finish but
still be just yanking away like a
lawnmower just I I know I look like a
performer but I'm a little bit camera
shy you know I don't understand how you
could just make somebody responsible for
your deviancy is like that
never done anything like that you know
low-level [ __ ] boys [ __ ] you know I hit
on my chiropractors receptionist that
was a low point
don't do that what are you doing buddy
you're not here to get shows you're here
to get looked at you know maybe maybe
take the day off stallion hey what do
you do when you're not here at the
office oh well I take classes at UCLA I
like to make my own jewelry what do you
do when you're not paying a medicine man
to sort through your crumbling
infrastructure well I like to iron my
money
I like to charge my bluetooths I like to
keep my Bluetooth charged like to keep
my Bluetooth fully charged I'm an
established elder statesman with lots of
business to attend to buy a bluetooth
and I will tell anybody that'll listen
what it was like to write directions
down on paper
you remember that of course you don't
Oh get out of here that's not the exit
I'm back get it no pretty sure I could
vote when you were born I'll see you
later
you did used to have the right
directions down on paper that's two for
the full two generations that have no
idea what I'm talking about when I say
that now first of all you were tethered
to a wall and you had to wait for the
person at the place where you were
calling to get back to their wall
then they had to answer the phone
without even knowing who was calling
them yeah you may have to hear in
someone's voice that they regretted
answering the telephone
[Applause]
that's a part of socialization that has
just gone away and then if you could get
their address from them before they
thought of a reason not to give it to
you then you wrote it down on paper and
you went and got marijuana I tried to
explain this to a 24 year old recently
she looked at me like I told her I
fought in the Korean War
wait what how did you send text message
how did you get text messages you
couldn't do it
only the president could send and
receive text messages on a cell phone
the size of a refrigerator from the
basement of the Pentagon nobody got
engaged that's
goddamn right met my fiancé at a yoga
studio outside of yoga I followed her
out of yoga and she she saved me from
being the kind of person that would
follow a woman out of yoga real quick
what'd you just say to me get over here
do you do this all the time don't answer
that
yes I'll marry you
no I highly recommend it fellas get your
get get yourself an alibi that's what I
say a lot of accusations flying around
out there fellas
you get yourself a character witness
and you do what they say
and find somebody you like what they
like and or you just find somebody likes
what they like enough to not give a [ __ ]
whether or not you like what they like
you you do what they say and then maybe
they'll testify on your behalf in a
court of law
Nate when Rich hid the woman's March oh
well my gal works real hard so she
wanted to sleep in and then she put her
feet my mouth how about that I hosted
the woman's March I hosted one woman's
March how about that think globally act
locally that's what she tells me
as she jams her foot in my mouth is that
too much for the album we can cut we can
cut anything out we can cut anything out
[Applause]
no you know who I really feel for
Melania Trump I feel the most for
Melania Trump because she's clearly a
spy she's the most spy looking spy that
I've ever seen please that is the most
lizard looking I spy with my little eye
the First Lady of the United States of
America is a [ __ ] spy that is
his spy and she is sad because she can't
do her job she was trained to [ __ ] in 20
languages or whatever she was trained to
do and it's just she's just the most
bondo and looking Bond villain I've ever
seen if they were auditioning for a bond
donat Melania Trump walked in they'd be
like it's too much it's too much
we're sorry thank you Melania thank you
very much
little on the nose thank you we are
going for subtlety and good luck you're
doing great work but not on this project
and she just you've seen her she just
stands behind him she's just like oh
please Vladimir just let me use my
knives please why did you raise me in
laboratory an active volcano if I can't
use my knives Oh Melania you've got to
let Donald MacDonald
it please it's Americas enjoy ourselves
just be poison one step child I will
just poison one step child
I'm so good at poisoning stepchildren
please I will clip brake cables on Air
Force One in parachutes two safeties in
Bahamas please I've been in LA for ten
years now I like it I like it a lot
la is at least perfect it makes perfect
sense to me at this point
sure plastic surgery is an ethnicity but
it just don't New York if New York was
in Hawaii and that's you know it's
disorienting cuz you're like why are you
acting like that you know it's like man
we act oh you've been in traffic for
four hours for the last 30 years okay I
get it every day for the last 30 years
okay that makes sense there is uh there
is a lot of plastic surgery in my
neighborhood there's a lot of plastic
surgery and I just I feel bad for
plastic surgeons could you never see the
victories
[Applause]
you always see the losses I mean you
never miss it when somebody looks like
an armadillo with a human mouth you know
but nobody ever shouts out their plastic
surgeon you know people love their dry
cleaner in LA every dry cleaner I go to
there's headshots all over LA why do you
think that your dry cleaner gives a [ __ ]
about your career it's so strange I've
been in dozens of dry cleaners in LA
I've never recognized a single headshot
if you are dropping off your own dry
cleaning your dry cleaner doesn't want
your headshots okay you booked one but
light commercial the victory parade
starts as your dry cleaners they've
never seen your Bud Light comer seen the
TV in the back it's either Telemundo or
the Korean Channel that I don't know
I've never seen that that channel
outside of a dry cleaner I like my
neighborhood I do I live in I live next
to a Yacht Club I live next to a Yacht
Club and a rent-controlled apartment
because I like to eat rich people on
their toes
I like to make eye contact while I hang
my laundry from my patio furniture
no I live next to a yacht club because
gentrification is a problem so I'm not
afraid to live in a neighborhood that is
nice and has always been nice
I don't need my neighborhood to have
been taken from generations of Latino
families or in this neighborhoods case
taken from generations of Korean
families who took it from generations of
Latino families this is too close to
home for some of you or should I say too
close to someone else's home sure what I
like for my yoga studio to have been a
food pantry of course I would
would I like to go to a chocolatier that
used to help single mothers do their
taxes obviously I would like that but
some of us have to diversify Marina del
Rey California it's a nice neighborhood
I could jump in some neighborhoods any
neighborhood with graffiti on the trees
by the trees willing to bet that your
target audience does not read trees any
neighborhood with a Boost Mobile store I
feel like 12 liquor stores can't hurt a
community like 1 Boost Mobile Starbucks
why are we letting boost to do this to
our communities far as I could tell
Boost Mobile only works at bus stops on
speakerphone
it's no way to communicate I stay in my
car so they don't get sucked into a
conversation that was not meant for me
anybody here like to put your phone on
speaker in public yeah any other
full-blown Psychopaths in all right who
do you think you are who the [ __ ] do you
think you are that you're gonna make us
listen to the whole thing you're gonna
make us listen to both sides of this
[ __ ] how far up your own ass do you
get cell phone reception this you're
gonna make us listen to both sides of
this [ __ ] don't get me wrong I like
technology it's a good sign I like
technology I'm not that good with it I
don't want to brag about being stupid
but I might have voted for Donald Trump
if he'd had told me that I would never
have to download Adobe Flash Player ever
again
[Applause]
please make it stop
I can't be the only one having this much
trouble with Adobe Flash Player I'm
pretty sure last week Adobe Flash Player
told me I needed Adobe Flash Player to
use Adobe Flash Player things make it
stop but he did not promise that so he's
a racist psychopath
again I love doing this bad joke for
Millennials they're just like you just
going to preferences you could shut the
[ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up
just
give me another Flash Player
somebody somebody invent a new Flash
Player
I'd be better invention than most of the
stuff on the market not in favor of
self-driving cars I think that's a bad
idea first of all nobody in this room
has ever felt confident sitting down on
a toilet with a sensor on it never one
time yeah because he knew you were gonna
get the fire hose you knew you were
gonna get public toilet water inside
your body and it doesn't leave you you
don't come back from that
I got toilet water from the Milwaukee
Airport from six years ago inside me
right now but that's what we're doing
with our inventions we're putting toilet
water inside each other
I don't know I think we are we don't we
can no longer tell the difference
between an invention and an idea used to
be easier you know here's a question
which came first the hose or the straw I
didn't know either
but I was pretty sure I could invent the
second one
same thing just smaller and backwards
I looked it up it was the hose the hose
was patented in 1668 the straw wasn't
patented until 1885 which means dead for
over 200 years people walked around like
[ __ ] drinking their gin tonics
through a goddamn garden hose
because they lived in a magical time
when when there was no difference
between ideas and inventions
anything could happen back then you know
and people had shame and humility and
they didn't think that they could run up
and patent a short straight backwards
hose for their gin and tonics before
sliced bread that's when that was
magical time they always talk about
since sliced bread they won't shut the
[ __ ] up about everything that happens
since sliced bread but can you imagine
what it was like living in a time when
portioning a loaf of bread made you a
force for change in the world oh my god
what else was still available you know
it's a magical time since sliced bread
nothing nothing worth a [ __ ] the twist I
find the twist hi you need the twist die
otherwise your sliced bread is all over
the floor
a couple things what whiteout oh good
you figured out that someone again want
to paint and half ounce bottles who's
going to be
profitable for your families now your
grandson gets laid in Cancun three times
a year Congrats on your patent but
kindly go [ __ ] yourself a lot of
supply-side inventions you know not
anything that we need just some that
somebody came up with and got somehow
got into the market and that's what
we're stuck with nothing no blankets
with sleeves bottled water and [ __ ]
supply-side inventions I don't know how
some of those [ __ ] maybe didn't look me
in my [ __ ] face and tell me that the
market demanded self-driving toilets
okay look me in my [ __ ] face and tell
me that at a bowling alley
you need self-driving toilets you can't
even keep doors on the stalls I'll flush
the toilet but I rented the shoes I'll
flush the toilet and a bowling alley I
got it every time I don't need spare me
the public enema thank you but that's
what we're doing we're putting toilet
water in each other I don't know who's
inventing this [ __ ] I know and I know
exactly who invented the automatic
toilet flushing system his name is John
T Barrett patent number us four seven
nine one seven nine
I googled it in the bathroom stall with
my pants around my ankles because I want
him dead now on his family dead
[Applause]
you are putting toilet water inside me
friends
buddy you do not deserve your mansion
I'm sorry I'm sorry that's just any mini
[ __ ] with Wi-Fi can be [ __ ]
Leonardo da Vinci no we already had
self-driving cars to call trains trains
that's what rains are that's what
they're gonna walk this back to because
these things the robots are gonna keep
killing people and they're gonna have to
keep they're gonna well what if we put
them in a row on a track we'll put them
on a track oh those trains okay those
trains
does anybody got the patent on trains
yeah what about trains with sleeves
[Applause]
Leonardo da Vinci yeah see that back
then anything was possible Leonardo
DaVinci got credit for over 500
inventions most of them were just
drawings in a notebook I think that's
awesome I also think the word doodle
hadn't been invented yet because that's
not how [ __ ] works now the reason is he
was that he was he lived an amazing life
he was a military contractor and a
member of a painters Union Wow that was
life life does not exist anymore you
either fly drone strikes or you like
watercolors you either murder people
with robots in the sky or you paint
sailboats can't do both not anymore you
want to murder people with robots in the
sky the first thing they do is make you
turn in your watercolors the military
knows painters make shitty killers also
if your painters are your killers
there's not much left to fight for
but can you imagine that getting credit
for just just being in history for your
your Trapper Keeper the patent troll
that's what he invented the patent troll
god forbid you made a prototype of a
tang kind of iron and steel sorry leo da
Vinci drew a picture of a rifle sticking
out of a turtle shell so we're gonna go
ahead and give him credit for the weapon
that wins World War two once you take
your non-functioning lawn mower back to
the river peasant we still let one guy
invent everything though Steve Jobs you
know there's a perfect example good
invention the iPhone changed society
supply-side invention the iPhone screen
because now all you iPhone people are
trapped you have to go to the Apple
store twice a year because it's the new
DMV and you gotta get your screens fixed
I've never seen an Android with a
cracked screen I've never seen an iPhone
that didn't look like it had been beaten
with a sock full of nickels there people
are viewing the world through the
shattered windshield of a fatal car
crash I could throw my phone out the
window of a moving car bounce back into
my hand mid-conversation there's nothing
left to invent anymore doesn't left for
[ __ ] to invent any more bait flavors
you could invent vape flavors
that's the
it's the last thing or there's a healthy
market out there for ruining everybody's
favorite childhood candy flavor
I used to vape before it was cool back
when there was only one vape flavor the
original vape flavor other people's to
heat us it's the best it's the best and
everybody loves it it's a hit other put
there's nothing better than when
somebody else's fajitas walk in the room
oh I'll bake the [ __ ] out of your
fajitas Oh God not cool they would say
as I hovered over their fajitas
you'll see I told them and I was right I
was right so now we live in innovate
based economy and all the kids are
hooked every kid in America has got a
car battery in their pocket that they
pull out and feed into their neck and
then make us sit in it look vape dorks
can you just blow it over your shoulder
I would be fine with vapes if you just
smokers blow it over their shoulder
you people trap us in your cotton candy
basement
it's disgusting ice I did I just taste
your lungs what is why would you make
that happen why would you make that area
what it was the woods on the bottle
because I taste butterscotch
flood-damaged that's what I taste what's
the how do they sell it to you well this
year is called dentist office toothpaste
everybody else around you tastes a
scented candle and a drainage ditch to
you it tastes like spearmint
we makes love weedvibes weedvibes for
the best smoke that window weed is
actually still not legal in the entire
country that's hilarious to me you can
eat weed now you didn't used to be able
to eat weed
I can eat wheat again the dosage is
right there it's beautiful
used to be real real Russian Roulette
eating weed back in the day yeah it was
not advisable I would do it it was not
advisable you didn't put one bullet and
a revolver you put five bullets in the
revolver and then maybe you didn't shoot
yourself in the face because you put
your hippie friend in charge of the
wheat butter you might have a nice day
in the park you might find out you were
allergic to your own brain
yeah yeah I have a demon allergy I found
that out early on allergic to my demons
and brownies with marijuana in them
unlock the gates to hell
eating weed was like the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man
candy strong enough to murder you with
childhood memories I used to eat weed
like Asians drink it didn't agree with
me and you could see it on my face thank
you for laughing at that that's a joke
about asianglow if you don't know what
asianglow is well then which one of us
is being more racist right now it's cuz
agents have a more common alcohol
allergy you get Rosie in the cheeks
because they're genetically more pure
sorry Nazis
they are they they didn't diversify like
some ethnicities and that's the process
through which humans build up a
tolerance to poisons like alcohol so if
you're good at drinking it's because
you're a mudblood pig person
we should probably get yourself a banjo
[Applause]
now everybody does something though eat
wheat or CrossFit people like to do
CrossFit
CrossFit's like if a panic attack was a
lifestyle it's community service without
the community I don't do CrossFit I just
helped my friends move that's really
what CrossFit is do you like helping
your friends move but don't have any
friends CrossFit I just like my activity
to have a point to it
you know I want a hoop or a net watch
going trick my body into thinking
there's a reason for this [ __ ] you
know something to go against even yoga
it's you versus whatever awful mixtape
the instructor has put together for you
whatever hour and 15 minutes of world
music she's assembled over eight trips
to Burning Man or some [ __ ] trying to
learn how to meditate for the first time
she pops in a 90-minute bongo solo from
her ex-boyfriend who put this woman in
sparks in my spirituality some of you
think you maybe never tried yoga but you
have if you've ever tried to take a [ __ ]
in an airplane bathroom
[Music]
[Applause]
mirror
here you get real in touch with yourself
to an airplane yoga
[Music]
no I do like sports I'm a big football
fan excited for football season every
time I watch the NFL not realize how far
away I am from a career in the NFL
last season I saw a guy run a kick back
for a touchdown and it's the hardest
thing I can imagine doing in sports and
he as he got into the clear the last 30
40 yards you know he he watched himself
on the jumbotron if I see myself
reflected in more than one mirror at one
time I lose control of all my motor
skills
this dude is running from 11 300-pound
murder machines
still has time to watch television
himself on live television if I see
myself on the security monitor at
7-eleven
I felt flop into a Dorito wrap my career
in the league is over you ever see
yourself on the monitor you never do
anything cool you know never do anything
productive on the security monitor you
catch yourself catch a glimpse of
yourself it's just a ghost of Christmas
present just showing your life to you oh
there you are Nate again hunched over a
counter just a failed pile of a consumer
inaccurate inefficient taking tube socks
back to a Walmart on a Wednesday
afternoon
good lord but yeah go ahead scratch your
leg with your other leg this is really
happening
yeah we're trying to find it what you
try to find it
[Applause]
for those of you listening at home I
just played a video of an ostrich
chasing a man on a mountain bike no I I
couldn't be more supportive of the
players I don't know this whole anthem
protest it's clearly an important moment
there's clearly a problem in society 1
in 15 black men are in prison right now
one in 15 white men are at Starbucks
right now and if one in 15 white men
were in prison prison might have
Starbucks so why people just act like
you know a little bit right it's the
players aren't complaining because
somebody put pickles on their hamburgers
right people are getting shot in the
[ __ ] streets but with taxpayer money
I don't know maybe all the good cops
became firefighters I don't think that's
true but you never see a firefighter
beat the [ __ ] out of an old lady he's
saved from a burning building
stop smoldering ma'am
you never see a university or
firefighter tase a cat out of a tree why
people are acting like black people
should be acting there was a black NRA I
would join it today out of principle
white people are losing it couldn't even
handle when they did endzone dances well
NFL players couldn't do an endzone dance
for 20 years that was a dark time in the
league I can't think of a better time to
dance than when you score a touchdown in
the National Football League you score a
touchdown that fo you should have to
dance for 90 seconds this should be how
they determine the extra point
no more kickers you can make a kicker
dance put a helmet on a skinny white
dude make them do the worm real good
seven points
fat kicker please make up that kicker
dance nothing will bring the country
together like a fat kicker dancing why
wouldn't they why why do we care so much
about football players what is this why
does it shake us to our core I don't
know why we get so puritanical it's not
the Vatican it's mortgage bank that
won't be the same name filled in five
years anyway when you do their dance
moves
we will bulldoze Indian burial grounds
to build a Chipotle I can't watch a wide
reciever salsa dancing Buffalo
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah white people are losing them I can
say that I have a white friend white
people stay in the pocket you're gonna
be okay I'm gonna be okay you don't have
to retreat into your lizard brain
elected a tantrum build a wall Mexicans
are digging tunnels
if you're gonna be racist be a smart
racist you just can make them feel
better about their tunnels wall we're
specks of dust hurling through the
universe nobody knows the answer I'm
whining about toilet water but you might
as well build a door in the woods
you might as well build a door in the
woods and lock it if it makes you feel
better kids and cages you should be
ashamed of yourself you're [ __ ]
losing at white people yeah damn
what are you scared of what do you
thinks gonna happen rapists they [ __ ]
came through thousands of hundreds of
miles thousands of miles or rocks and
[ __ ] sank and in the heat the moon if
the moon was the Sun not for
air-conditioning not for not for a job
to make a better life for their family
no to breathe it's not bad Mexicans want
to rape
Cornie white lie you [ __ ] [ __ ]
nobody wants to [ __ ] your sloppy maul
daughters
[Applause]
if there is a race war I just hope they
don't settle it with a race
[Applause]
my people will lose that I don't care
how much CrossFit we do we're losing
oh you know who would win that race the
ostrich the ostrich you win that race
hands down I don't know why there's no
football teams with an ostrich for a
mascot real quick they're the fastest
animal on two legs and it's not even
close I says I did see a video of it
turned my world upside down
did you know an ostrich can run 50 miles
an hour with no arms
when was the last time you tried to run
full speed with your arms behind your
back give it a shot you'll lose all your
teeth
ostriches is up there just running with
its neck up here just a feat of
Engineering
specific a goin man but we made up this
horrible lie about the ostrich that
their cowardly but they stick their
heads in the sand they don't female
ostriches will turn their eggs with
their faces it's pretty hardcore
actually and then the rest of them have
to get out of view because their heads
they got those big food faces they're 20
feet up in the air they're like a
balloon at Coachella that you find your
friends with lion some Tigers like meet
me at ostrich for lunch
they're out there man they're nature's
kick returner how are they not at least
one football team just dipping and
diving just running
not in the caged in Van wondering when
they stop serving brunch at the resort
they're out there running for their
lives they'll run up next to you on the
highway a week it's your girl turn your
head for a second ostriches taking your
girl that Denny's right up under your
nose and she'll be back because he's an
ostrich
you're gonna have to hide that from your
families you better hope that on your
wedding day
you don't have to SiC your groomsmen on
some emotional ostrich outside the
church dipping and diving doesn't care
about your groomsmen so run it from
lions and tigers and bears for Millenia
treat your groomsmen like a goddamn cone
drill all right
steppin on your tin cans on your
honeymoon mobile [ __ ] promises that
your girl through a rolled-up window
what's he sayin your mother-in-law will
scream posture just tastes good it
tastes good
compress it I'm impressed that they're
still alive horrifying feet the ostrich
oh you thought I was done
track star legs dinosaur feet that's
ostrich has no business leaving the
house in the morning with its feet
uncovered no if there is a race war
they'll probably settle it with assault
rifles I think it was 20 maybe 25 mass
shootings ago I got into a fight with a
kid on Facebook cuz I'm a grown man that
gets in facebook fights and he told me
that my car was just as dangerous as an
ar-15 assault rifle I said hold the [ __ ]
on driving Oh five Honda Accord one of
the windows doesn't work but okay 19
year old from Arkansas let's talk about
this for three hours
I'm not good at time management all
right I mean it's not even realistic
like we've lost something in this
country
I'll pretend okay I'll pretend if I
wanted to kill as many people as I could
with my oh five Honda Accord okay I
would get in it
I will go to Walmart and I would buy an
ar-15 assault rifle because those things
are [ __ ] meat ruiners we don't and we
know it it's ridiculous
you don't hundreds of millions of
Americans who get to work everyday
riding their ar-15s [ __ ] idiot this
is not realistic okay
I don't these are poor [ __ ] lies that
you're telling us we don't you don't
need two assault rifles to raise four
kids in the suburbs it's nonsense
it's nonsense we have these [ __ ] ups I
don't buy into this good guy with a gun
fantasy that's just some worship that
they tell men with no law-enforcement
experience no military training so that
they can entertain some fantasy about
saving a shopping mall like they
wouldn't shoot the cashier at gadzooks
while they were trying to get their
Glock out of their hooded sweatshirt if
you don't feel safe without an assault
rifle it tells me a couple things about
you first of all you never made clean
contact with a pinata
[Applause]
you were straight air balls the whole
time in nothing but air you didn't make
clean contact one time other kids did
the damage they got candy you got tears
it taught you to hate yourself it taught
you to hate Mexicans I don't want you
around guns and I definitely don't want
you around people with your guns man
most people don't have your candy the
people that take your candy are long
gone okay and if they did you would just
ruin the candy because your new wiffle
ball bat shoots 800 rounds per minute
all right let's lighten the mood
abortion I support a woman's right to an
abortion obviously mostly because I have
paid for one and when you go to the
school you root for the team
[Applause]
yeah learned a lot from that first of
all if men could get pregnant you could
get an abortion at a [ __ ] atm it's
not even it's not even realistic that's
if men could get pregnant part of
becoming a notary public would be
learning how to administer an abortion
you could go to FedEx and get your
weekends back we'd be giving them to
each other no guy in this room oh I
guess I'll just do what the Good Book
says get the [ __ ] out of here
it's just men controlling women I don't
care how Christian you are if you needed
one win to make your fantasy football
playoffs and Tom Brady got pregnant you
[Music]
would want that handled in the locker
room like a sprained ankle
lie to me all you want just don't lie to
yourselves gentlemen I learned a lot
from that woman told me she was pregnant
it's like alright well this is more
difficult for you than it is for me so I
support what you want to do it's your
whatever you choose I support I just
want to do I just want you know that I
want what you want she looked me dead in
the face she said oh that's nice but
what I want is for you to know that I
don't give a [ __ ] what you want and I
fell in love because I knew [ __ ] was
going to get handled that is some case
you're at [ __ ]
that's not how somebody that wants to
start a family with you talks to your
face
[Applause]
um
no I get I I don't I don't understand
our obsession with guns but I I do
understand the the fear component
because our brains don't give a [ __ ]
about us it's not really
we're not even control in the least bit
like I grind my teeth that's something a
lot of people do I think but I did a
whole life and I used to wake my pennies
a pop my teeth like I have to wear these
big stupid thing
and because when I go to sleep at night
my brain eats my teeth
eats my teeth that's the worst thing you
could eat that's above glass and
concrete glass has food value eats my
teeth you need your teeth you gotta have
your teeth cavemen you broke your jaw he
died he couldn't even help through a
straw
there was no Jamba Juice now I could get
new teeth what my brain doesn't know
that so it's just altogether destructive
and I understand it I understand that we
were just limited by our own our own
existences I saw a guy in a Nissan Versa
with a Hawaii license plate not in
Hawaii
[Music]
which music he bought a boat ticket for
a Nissan Versa and I just want to say
man you got trust you gotta trust
yourself to get to another Versailles
you're gonna get there man life is a
series of verses it's a fifteen hundred
hour boat ticket it's at least half the
value of a Nissan Versa what are you
doing you can't do that you I'm not
sayin ditch it in a parking lot walk
away like there's a bomb in the trunk
I'm saying get on Honolulu Craigslist
flip that verso it's probably a very
nice Craigslist in Honolulu have a
little fun get a couple things for the
road flip your versa add it to your
versa boat ticket money find a new verse
start a new life with a new verse up
that's in the same place in life as you
are that wants the same things that you
do is other fish in the sea but you
don't want any old fish you want your
versa
you got it in your head that that's the
only verse although it is the only versa
in the sea there's never been another
verse on a boat before
you made that happen friend that is a
prison of your own design you got
emotional about your first verse I
started sailing it all over the goddamn
Pacific Ocean and now you're stuck in
Nebraska with the Versa they can't stop
thinking about Hawaii
[Applause]
but it's hard to trust yourself it's
hard to trust yourself your brain will
do whatever it wants I went skydiving
and I was always told that skydiving
felt like flying it does not
you're definitely following you are
falling very fast then you have a small
French woman on your background she's
the only thing that's gonna save you you
are very happy that she's there but what
happens is you fall for long enough that
your brain tricks you into thinking that
you're flying well okay if your brain
can trick you into thinking that you're
flying then your brain can definitely
trick you into thinking that you're
falling one of those things you do
naturally and I don't know white folks
just fall slower maybe don't get the F
maybe just get to F 150 next time maybe
don't eat the whole dessert pizza
tonight
I'm sorry but it's not Mexicans fault
that you didn't make the payments on
your pontoon boat
and it's not about race but I don't know
somebody tell white people that it's
about class and consumerism and just
this [ __ ] absurd culture that we're
living I traveled a whole country in the
last couple weeks I was in Ohio Michigan
Indiana Wisconsin Illinois and North
Dakota or north carolina and every
[ __ ] exit on every [ __ ] highway as
a Bob Evans and a [ __ ] Cracker Barrel
and Mexicans didn't do that dude they
got you to stop on this life you are
just preferred customers man it's not
you can make it from Salt Lake City to
Pittsburgh only using drive-throughs
okay Mexicans didn't do that and I get
double-digit mailers a month for you get
those invitations from banks to just
ruin your own credit I don't like those
I don't like how much they know I don't
like their tone I just feel like they're
just calling me an [ __ ] every time a
night banks here listen we saw that you
had no money we were wondering if maybe
we should have it
hey Nate banks again listen we sat down
with our lawyers and crunched a few
numbers turns out you are our kind of
[ __ ] consumer how'd you like to
borrow $10,000 you pay us back thirteen
thousand dollars or you take your time
with that you pay us back 97 thousand
[ __ ] dollars
[Applause]
how about it Nate ha we just want you to
have any little horseshit you set your
little heart on you know little trinkets
or nonsense yeah you can finance things
you don't need or you can finance things
you don't need to finance we're a
one-stop shop for horrible financial
decisions huh how about it yeah you ever
charge a lapdance online we support that
how'd you like to finance five years
worth the almond milk we saw you did
that in 2006 Nate how'd you like to
how'd you like to buy a house you'll
never own how about it how you want to
be underwater on a house huh where the
goddamn beach hey why don't you rent
your rooms Nate we just want you to have
the most least valuable [ __ ] you could
possibly own would you please rent your
hubcaps goddamn it huh
Nate don't just not own your car not own
several parts of your car originated
several bad investments assemble an
entire vehicle out of horrible financial
decisions it's your own transformer do
you like science fiction me
it's Optimus subprime how about it Nate
it's a car that you own that turns into
a car you don't own anymore maybe I
should go back to check look-see me here
so use a checkbook yeah so I pull a
checkbook out in the express lane at the
grocery store
exactly you know next time that happens
just forget about your afternoon take a
step back you watch the rest of the line
lose their minds there was four people
in front of me they all folded their
arms and started looking for eye
contacts like oh my god checkbook are
you seeing this checkbook please aisle
five checkbook get in the game I'm gonna
need you to stare through the back of
this man's skull for the duration oh my
god died in your shoes old man you die
in your shoes in front of my son
whose palpable hate and he was like 8090
maybe never sent an email if you've
outlived your life expectancy 25 items
or less does not apply to you you do
what you got to do he was awesome he had
fun with it he clearly liked to do it he
likes to press pause on people's day you
stared him down a little bit like does
anybody have a pen I'm sorry am i
putting you out right now why don't you
stop counting the items in my cart how
about that what do you narc if they made
one big can of fish I'd have bought it
but they don't so I had to buy 40 small
ones when I start counting [ __ ] how many
worthless generations am i looking at
right now 34 45 what are you 19 back
there checkbook Google too but learn
something cupcake it's a contract
between people from back and we're worth
a [ __ ] well I don't need the date
sweetheart I got it here in my paper
hand calendar you guys that's been it
I'm an 8 thank you so much
thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you